hi welcome to jsconf mexico today we're
going to take a look at javascript tests
and node the browser nci
now here's the part where i tell you i
am definitely going to post the slides
on my site tonight but in this case
there are no slides this is it now the
code that we're going to look at is
online right now we can head off to
github and here's that github repository
now here we have a done folder and a
start folder that allows us to begin
and then you can compare your answer
with mine to see what i need to fix
now you can get to this github
repository really easily from
robrich.org let's click on robrich.org
click on presentations here's javascript
tests and node the browser nci the code
is online right now
while we're here at robrich.org let's
click on about me and we'll see some of
the things that i've done recently
i'm a microsoft mvp a friend of redgate
and a docker captain i'm also a cyril
developer advocate
if you're struggling with your data mesh
i would love to learn from you az give
camp is really fun azgive camp brings
volunteer developers together with
charities to build free software we
start building software friday after
work sunday afternoon we deliver
completed software to the charities
sleep is optional caffeine provided if
you're in phoenix come join us for the
next a z give camp or if you'd like a
gift camp here in mexico or wherever
you're connecting from hit me up on
email or twitter and let's get a gift
camp in your neighborhood too
some of the other things that i've done
i worked on gulp as a core contributor
in version two in version three
and i replied to a.net rocks podcast
episode they read my comment on the air
they sent me a
mug so there's my claim to fame so let's
dig in now i've opened the start folder
here inside vs code and let's create a
new file hello world.js and let's get
time to first it it
should pass
now with any it function we will have an
assert
true
reason
now we do need to import assert so let's
import
assert from assert
and that is our first test
let's run it
cd21
npm test
and we have one passing test
excellent
now i did do a few things behind the
scenes but our goal was time to first it
we got there really quickly
here in our package json i did install
mocha and chai so that we have those
available mocha is our test runner and
chai is our assertion library so that we
can validate that our results are as we
expect
and when we do npm test i want to run
mocha
so we have our test
and we can assert something in this case
i just asserted true
and give it a reason that will display
when it fails we can name our test we
can also group them
so let's start by testing this add
function now in this case the add
function is pretty straightforward but
it'll help us build up to some really
robust tests so i'm going to create a
new file here in the test folder i'll
call this test add.js
and let's import
chai
from
nope not like that like that
and uh we'll import
the add library from
up one directory add
now that we have our libraries imported
let's describe our test
and this is that grouping and so in this
case it will be the add function
and we can give it a scope so anything
inside this describe block will be in
the ad group okay
now let's say it
should
add two plus two well two plus two i
could accidentally multiply so i'm gonna
say two plus
three now let's give it a test body
and here in our test body we can do the
standard pattern so we'll do
arrange
act
and assert
now what do we want to do we want to act
and we want to say const
actual
equals add
x and y
okay
so let's say const x equals two const y
equals three now we've set up our
expectations and we've accomplished our
task let's validate the result
expect actual
to be
to equal
expected
so we need another expected variable
const expected equals five
and now we've got our test this arrange
act assert pattern is really helpful in
testing we'll set up our expectations
we'll accomplish a task and then we'll
validate that the result is as expected
now
in javascript we can also concatenate
strings with plus so let's do that
should add
a and b
so x is a and y is b and we expect this
to be a b
and now let's run our test again npm
test
and we should get our hello world test
in addition to our
um oh
ad imported from
module not found
oh i bet i didn't import this correctly
add.js there we go
there so now we've got two passing tests
and a nice fail
now let's validate that we can get a
failing test i'm going to say abc
and we'll be able to see not only our
passing test but also our failing test
and the line number that it failed what
we expected and what we actually got
and that's why i like the chai library
is because it's really clear what the
actual and the expected are
with assert we can just say
assert
actual
equals expected
but now we don't know what is the actual
and what is expected that's why i really
like the chai library so let's make this
test pass and we can validate that our
test is as we expect perfect
now like any good developer
let's copy this and let's create a
subtract
test test
dot js
and
in subtraction we don't do this but we
can say should
subtract
two
from three so in this case x is three y
is two and we expect this to be one
let's run our test and see how it works
oh
importing a few things we oh
yes i should import expect from chai
not just chai
so let's fix up this test as well
there we go
now that we've got our subtract test
let's run npm test and we'll see what we
got
oh
unexpected token semicolon
um
on
line
oh expected one
there we go
npm test and we've got our passing test
oh callback is not a function hmm
let's dig in what does subtract do
differently well in this case subtract
uses callbacks
so let's see if we can test a callback
now in this case we will say error
and
um
actual
and
we'll move our assert here into this
and now we've got our test except for
how do we know when we're done
well
mocha actually provides a really good
way to say when we're done we can just
when we call this
we will be done
we can also um expect
error
to equal
null just to validate that it is as
expected and now our test will pass
excellent
now what if we don't call done now
this is an asynchronous test that does
nev does not complete after two seconds
mocha will time out and if we need to we
can adjust that timeout value
so we've called done and everything
works great
so there's a
callback based test now in the case of
multiply we have promises so let's build
a promise based test of test multiply.js
and so let's grab our subtract test
and set it in place here we'll
swap subtract
for
multiply
and let's adjust this should multiply
two and three
so i'm going to make this two and this
three and we expect this to be six
that's pretty straightforward but now we
have a promise based test
so i'm going to say
instead of actual here
oh it looks like we might have messed up
our subtract test too
we don't need this actual
now i'm going to test this result
and now instead of um doing this i will
say
dot then
and i will pass in the actual value this
way
now this function that i call when i get
my then
can
now do the expected content i no longer
have an error that i can do but now i
can also still call done when i'm done
here
let's
run this test and validate it works as
expected
yes excellent
now this test was for promises but we
can also instead of passing in done and
calling it we can just return
a promise to
mocha and when that promise resolves it
knows that it's done and by comparison
throw new error
fail
if we have a failing test we can call
npm test and we'll get that error as
well
now that's excellent so how would we
test then
let's modify these parameters how would
we test async and await
well in a similar way that we can return
a promise
we can
await
so let's have this
async function here we'll say 3
times 4 is 12
and now we can say const actual equals
await multiply
and we'll do our standard assert here
and because it's an async function
then that will work just fine
let's run this and we get great results
our divide test is uh synchronous so
let's come back to add and we'll copy
this
and we'll say test
divide
and we can paste this into place add
becomes divide
and we can divide
over 2
and that will be 1.
now there is another case where should
divide by 0 can be a thing so let's say
x is 2 and y is zero now in this case we
expect an exception
so let's do that let's say let's try
and catch here
and we can say we expect this to be
can't
divide by zero
and here we'll say
actual equals error.message
so we're not actually grabbing the
results here but we will have to say let
actual
and now we can expect
now we can validate that that works as
expected well even better let's take a
look at the code it returns so let's say
the code is one two three four five and
now we can run this test
now we run this test ooh
we expected undefined to equal one two
three four five it sounds like we didn't
throw our exception let's take a look at
our divide code and it looks like
someone was helpful and decided the math
worked differently
no let's not do that let's say const
error equals new error
can't
divide by zero
and we will say error.code is one two
three four five and throw error okay now
with that in place that was great we
were able to use our test to be able to
discover the sharp parts of our code
so we created an async and a weight test
we created a promise based test we
created a callback test and we created a
synchronous test we used test to
discover our libraries to validate our
libraries to even find edge cases that
we wanted to prove including adding
strings and dividing by zero
now how would we add this into node well
we've done it in node how would we add
this into a browser
well the cool part here is that i we can
just say um
to
uh we can do um
uh
mocha
it moka
init
uh nope
npx mocha init
and i'll give it a folder and we're
ready to go
now that we've done this init it's going
to spit out a few files it we have this
index.html
that will call into mocha and call into
our tests
okay
let's also add
um
node modules
chai
um
chai.js
there we go so now we have chai included
in our solution and now let's go add all
of our uh
content we'll have add dot js and
subtract.js
and
multiply.js and
divide
and we'll also include the test variants
of those as well
so let's say test add
and test subtract and test multiply and
test divide let's go grab those files
that we just built and set them into
place
now in this case i don't have any
build system i'm just including the
content here in my page but i do need to
adjust these ever so slightly
now previously we just said import
now they're included in the page so we
don't need to do that but we will say
const expect
expect equals chi dot expect
cool
we'll do that inside of each function
knowing that the browser has already
imported these
and
we'll be ready to go
now the cool part is we didn't really
need to change the logic of our tests
it's still just javascript we just need
to update the way that we import it
and we don't need this one at all
okay so now we have this
index.html page let's load that in a
browser here and take a look at our
tests
now i love this page because it runs
each of the tests we can drill into a
particular group and drill even into a
test and it'll show us the details of
that test now in this case we have a
failure should divide by zero well it
looks like we're doing the correct
result but hmm
let's take a look at this divide code
and yep it looks like we still have that
same bug let's come back and grab the
bug fix here for our divide code and
we'll put that into place
divide
and we've got passing test now now the
cool part about this is it's just a
browser so if i open the chrome
developer tools i can take a look at the
sources and if i want to for example
debug this divide test i can set a break
point right here i can refresh my page
and i can step into
and over my test so let's watch it throw
the error there and we'll catch it and
we can see that we've got the results
now probably i didn't do it in time so
yep the done timeout failed there but we
can see how we can debug through our
tests in a really elegant way here
mocha in a page is great so now how do
we implement this inside of continuous
integration in a devops pipeline
hey devops person can you just like open
this page and see how it works
uh yeah no that's where we reach for
karma
so
let's take a look inside this folder now
i've already installed
mocha and chai so let's say npx
karma init
now i like karma in that it kind of
interviews me and lets me know what
details i need for my thing so i'm going
to say i'm using the mocha framework do
i want require.js no i don't what
browsers would i like to use chrome is
great and i could choose others if i
wanted to as well in this case i'll just
choose chrome where are my test files
star.js
and what do i want to ignore
node modules
and now i've got the content that i want
to do i want karma to re-run on any test
change yes i do
and it dumps out the content into this
karma.config basically just the results
of all of those questions
so here's that karma config and i do
want to include the chai library there
as well but i could adjust the answers
that i gave there
the progress reporter is great here's
the port that it'll run on the
log level auto watch is set to true i
could adjust the browsers if i wanted to
include more and
it will run forever perfect
now i did add inside package.json to be
able to run
karma but let's just run it from the
command line
so i will say
npx
karma oh we first need to set our test
files into place so let's go grab all of
these
test files
and we'll set those in place now that
we've got all of our libraries and test
files
npx karma start
and
now it will kick off our tests
now the cool part about this is it's
going to launch
so i went offline and i found the error
i had excluded
node modules which excluded mocha and
chai which meant that i couldn't get
access to my test hmm
let's try this again and now we see that
it opens up a new version of chrome now
this version of chrome over here is not
my standard version of chrome it
launches in a different version of
chrome so that i don't have any of my
browser plugins installed or any of my
cookies that might interfere with my
tests now these are unit tests they're
not integration tests users aren't
clicking through buttons but we can
still debug our tests and take a look at
it but we can see that we've got our
tests and most of them passed but we
still divide by zero here hmm that's not
great let's come in here to our
divide and take a look at it oh yep
we've still got that bug let's pop open
divide.js and we'll go grab our fix
and set it in place here now because
karma is doing a watch it will
automatically rerun those tests i'll
come back into my console and i see i
now have successful tests
that's perfect
now in this case we did an npx karma
start so we're continuously running but
we could also override this in a
in a package.json so here in my
package.json i say npm test is karma
start single run and i want to run in
these two browsers chrome headless and
firefox headless so let's do that npm
test
and now i'm running all of my unit tests
inside each browser
in this case we had a bunch of tests and
we see that they executed correctly in
both browsers we have 16 successful
tests this was excellent we were able to
run our tests inside of node inside of a
browser where we could debug it and
inside of karma so that we could get it
inside of a integration test we saw how
we could do synchronous tests callback
based tests asynchronous tests with
promises and
async and await tests
we saw how we could use test to be able
to validate our code discover problems
in our code and even flex the edge cases
associated with our code
the code that we just built is up online
in this github repository and you can
get to it really easily from robrich.org
i'll be in that spot where the
conference is designated for a live q a
thank you for joining us for javascript
tests in node the browser nci